I want to be really clear the odds of a
manhole in a London Street suddenly
exploding while you're next to it are
tiny this is not something to worry
about and the company that handles the
cables under London's streets is
spending a lot of money fixing them up
but yeah about once or twice a month on
average somewhere in London a bit of
pavement just goes but no one wants to
license security camera footage of
actual pavement explosions - just
someone on YouTube and no one wants to
be interviewed about it either so
instead we are going to create our own
underground explosion right here with
the help of a friendly pyrotechnician
and the easy answer to my London's
pavements keep exploding well it would
be electrical faults and that's what the
news often blames a seasons change the
ground is going to get warmer and cooler
it's going to expand and contract rain
and subsidence will move the soil and
over the course of decades that is gonna
steadily wear out the 36,000 kilometers
of electrical cables and
hundred-thousand electrical junction
boxes that are under London
most of those were laid decades ago it's
a big city
things will break but an electrical
fault won't make an explosion if
electricity goes somewhere it shouldn't
then the circuit breakers that control
the grid will detect that and shut it
off right away the trouble is that
there's a lot of other old stuff under
London streets including gas pipes a
steady slow gas leak in a pipe might not
be detected for a while and in that time
the gas can spread a long distance
through narrow underground tunnels so if
you've got gas in a tight underground
space where it can't expand thank you
and an electrical spark to set it off
well that's all we're doing here under
that cover there is a fuel source not
enough room for it to expand and
something to make an electrical spark
that's all you need for an explosion
firing the hole
[Music]
this looks devastating in slow-motion
the burst of flame the flying manhole
cover at 1,800 frames a second on a zoom
lens it looks like it could do serious
damage but even this dramatized
explosion made with the help of a pyro
technician this worst-case scenario is
actually not that bad I tried to do the
cool guys don't look at explosions shot
and when you take away all this style
firing the hole it had hurt if you are
standing on it sure but like I said it's
not something to be worried about
you